que demande-t-il
chaque fois qu'on ne peut pas aussi on
sait pas ce qu'ils espèrent un vrai
changement pas là heureusement
toujours maculées
de toute façon c'est bien comment les
mettre à tout les mêmes dit de toute
façon d'occuper les multiplie les
tournées vol de toute façon ceux qui
parlent de changement te perds ma piste
et c'est encourageant
les promesses gomez avec ce panneau ghz
comme égal chez orange en tournoi quand
il coupe c'est one time je prends la qui
le droit d'être un jour ici noté je vois
tous les jours les riches qui ne pas se
débrouiller 10 février tous les crimes
de maquiller les prix augmentent tous
les jours y tout est devenu cher l'eau
le gaz et le tout en 8 août et de
friches et le prix du pain de belichick
l'appui du oui le privé l'appui du musée
plus des soins à l'hôpital est devenu si
on ne prend pas de miracle et simplement
les exports les actes tu parles charles
walo
duval
l'appui les plaies l'honneur lundi les
plaines et chômeurs au café du mec
honnête mais le système a rappelé aux
leurs la vie est pleine de sopra silence
en 2010 le coût tout en débit honnête
mais le système a rappelé combien moi
qui tu veux il ne boit carrelage espèces
de 3 pour la promotion et c'est qu'après
trois taxes il était alors de penser
notre pays c'est pas le choix on vient
te virer ou alors c'est l'interview de
terry qui tuent des dirigeants les
n'auraient plus les peaux et fourrures
qui vient du haut atteint le bas et
qu'il pourrit le flic dans le taximan
qui volent au cauchemar alors laurent
soumana que ces pistes plus ou bien
d'accès malgré tous les jours à la
richesse et l'opulence de tous ces maux
qui nous méprisent leurs estomacs
limousine du château dit les gars du
ghetto le ghetto les changements tout
près du ko
et
quand je dis on appelle le règne des
dictateurs le coeur de nîmes 1-1 par
mehdi moktar diallo si la france y ont
volé si la portion technique m par année
en plus des prix la méfiance et de
sympathie qui se resserre autour du cou
entre des coûts a tenté hier à berne
fillon perdent alors à penser à fuir
loin du continent benoît lecouls a pris
nos visas pour les prix de radio rsr
bout du compte il en valait la mère de
l'occident et wally shirt des bandes
d'ados tu veux savoir ce qu on va me
dire tu perds le temps tu te guette tous
quand je parle de révolution c'est pour
le bien des sentiments que julo le truc
et design des idées mais qu au pouvoir
le président tout prix pourtant c'est
toi qui veulent le pouvoir le truc
bizarre la mauvaise idée mais courtois
le président oublie oublie le président
deux
conférences avec des profs de fac années
90 voire de faire encore mieux faire